[Música]
yo acababa de cumplir 19 años y mi padre
ya estaba bajo tierra así fue como me
largué a Sao Paulo con una amiga sin
conocer a nadie al llegar estuvimos a
punto de conseguir un trabajo en una
joyería de la calle varón de
paranápiacaba faltaban pocos días para
navidad y la calle estaba temblorosa de
lucecitas y guirnaldas pero apenas la
dueña se enteró de que éramos degoyania
puso excusas y ya no nos quiso contratar
cuando estábamos por pisar la calle nos
llamó por un segundo creímos que tal vez
habría cambiado de opinión la mujer
tenía una curiosidad una pregunta que se
le salía de la garganta ustedes brillan
en lo oscuro
Liliana colanzio y muchas gracias por
compartir este momento con nosotros en
francés veinticuatro estás acá en la
feria del libro de Guadalajara para
presentar Tu última obra ustedes brillan
en lo oscuro ganadora de la séptima
edición del premio internacional Ribera
del duero Son seis cuentos que en el
tiempo de unas páginas exploran espacios
y personajes diferentes de dónde vienen
esas ideas cómo nacieron esas imágenes
de sus paisajes el primer cuento que se
llama la cueva lo escribí mientras
Pasaba una temporada en una residencia
artística precisamente aquí en México en
Oaxaca
y por esa época estaban saliendo
noticias acerca de huesos de animales
prehistóricos que habían sido
encontrados en la región lo cual disparó
mi imaginación
hacia atrás hacia el pasado profundo no
de hace miles de años y el cuento
entonces empezó con la pregunta por cómo
había sido la vida podría haber sido la
vida hace miles de años cuando los seres
humanos estaban en una situación de
supervivencia entonces Este cuento que
fue el primero que escribí
[Música]
contiene de alguna manera los las
preguntas los intereses los temas que
van a encontrarse en los demás y uno de
los temas principales es el tiempo no
los otros cuentos también
exploran el tiempo de diferentes maneras
por un lado está hay cuentos que hablan
sobre lugares
en ruinas sobre ciudades en ruinas y las
ruinas siempre nos remite a un tiempo
pasado y a una historia que se ha
quedado atrás pero que de alguna manera
continúa hablándole al al presente hay
otros cuentos también que imaginan
futuros y Hay también una
un deseo de descolocar un poquito el
tiempo en otros cuentos que tienen
elementos
de una realidad digamos un poco más
arcaica o tradicional como el cuento el
camino angosto pero que a la vez tiene
elementos de otra época no Entonces ese
es uno de los elementos que
conectan a todos los cuentos entonces
todo sale de una primera idea y después
ahí está afiliación al final en tu
proceso creativo es es todo está
fluyendo o cómo funciona este proceso
creativo y sientes que cambia tal vez
entre cada libro
definitivamente en cada libro intento
por lo menos
tener búsquedas diferentes Aunque hay
obsesiones que se van repitiendo de del
libro a libro no una obsesión que está
presente en mi libro anterior y que se
en esta es por ejemplo el tema de la
radiación el tema de la radiación va a
ser fundamental en este nuevo libro de
cuentos en dos de los relatos más largos
no Uno de ellos es ustedes brillan el
oscuro que está basado en el accidente
radiológico de goyania de 1987
en el cual dos recolectores de chatarra
ingresaron a un hospital abandonado
se llevaron equipos para tratar el
cáncer y al desmantelarlos para
venderlos como chatarra encontraron un
material radiactivo que emitía una luz
hermosa y que al llegar a la fuente de
esa luz
repartieron esos polvos que encontraron
en la cápsula que contenía
esta sustancia no y
provocaron involuntariamente una
contaminación
[Música]
a gran escala de la ciudad de guayania
que provocó además de la muerte de
varias personas la demolición de una
parte de la ciudad no de alrededor de
100 casas de la ciudad Entonces ese es
un tema que está presente pero también
hay cosas nuevas que quise hacer con
este con este libro no Mientras que la
mayoría de los relatos de mi libro
anterior están enfocados en un solo
personaje siguen la trayectoria de un
solo personaje en este libro quise
explorar narraciones más polifónicas
narraciones más fragmentarias que
pudieran dar cuenta de una temporalidad
más grande de diferentes puntos de vista
también y que pudieran moverse
hacia diferentes perspectivas no entre
diferentes perspectivas y sobre esta
forma el cuento cuando los periodistas
te preguntan por qué escribir cuentos
siempre contestas Que bueno es la
narrativa breve es lo que te sale
naturalmente y dijiste también que que
era el único medio capaz de canalizar tu
escritura al final parece que así que es
el cuento que te eligió y no tú que
elegiste el cuento de una cierta forma
en una cierta forma sí
aunque cada vez exploro más los límites
del cuento con otros géneros no por
ejemplo en ustedes brillan el oscuro hay
un una cercanía con
con otra formas con otras con otro
géneros
como el ensayo por ejemplo en la cueva
hay una
algunas escenas en las que la voz
narrativa se vuelve diferente y casi que
se aproxima más al al ensayo científico
no
hay otros Relatos en los que incluyo
también
por ejemplo
fragmentos de
crónicas periodísticas o de incluso
archivos
del juicio que se hizo a los
responsables de la contaminación en en
guayania no Y esta es una manera de que
el cuento entre en diálogo con otro
géneros me interesa la posibilidad del
cuento de acercarse a la poesía de
acercarse a al ensayo de acercarse a la
crónica de mutar de hibridarse de ser
otro no y de hecho hay algunos de mis
cuentos incluso que van
adquiriendo una una forma más parecida a
la novela corta que es también un
un género que me que me interesa
explorar no y Liliana afuera de de tu
papel de autora eres profesora enseñas
literatura latinoamericana y escritura
creativa en la universidad de Corner en
Estados Unidos nos podría hablar nos
podrías hablar un poquito de de este rol
y
como influencia tu Tu arte tu
creatividad
Lo lindo de enseñar es que te lleva a
releer
textos que
que han sido importantes para ti no
porque enseñamos aquellos textos que nos
han marcado que nos han fascinado y en
ese sentido hay una hay una cita que
creo que es de Rolands que me gusta
mucho que dice que los niños los viejos
y profesores Son los únicos que releen
muchas veces los libros no Y eso es Es
verdad
por otro lado enseñar me da la
posibilidad de no estar absolutamente
pendiente de lo más contemporáneo si
enseño
literatura contemporánea pero también
me da la posibilidad de mirar el siglo
19 a comienzos del siglo XX y de
detenerme allí y ver qué cosas de estas
épocas pasadas de la literatura que se
produjo en esas épocas todavía le hablan
al al presente no este semestre he
enseñado un curso de horror
latinoamericano que es un es un tema
cercano también a mis intereses como
como escritora
y es una forma de volver aquellas
fascinaciones que tengo como
como escritora de poder compartirlas y
de poder también
analizarla y para terminar esta esta
discusión contigo te quería preguntar
tu punto de vista como como Sientes como
ves
el escenario de la literatura boliviana
ahora hoy en día
hay movimiento en particular que te
interesa y voces que se destacan como
Cómo ves eso hay muchas voces potentes
en la literatura boliviana desde el
ensayo por ejemplo pienso
el ensayo feminista de María Galindo que
está también presente invitada en esta
feria que va a estar presentando
su
libro feminismo bastardos en estos días
por otro lado La Crónica tiene a una
autora aymara joven como la reina no que
publicó este año un libro muy muy
potente que se llama los hijos de boni
que ofrece una mirada muy política
incisiva e íntima de la ciudad del alto
donde ella nació y creció hay también
voces de desde la narrativa que están
irrumpiendo con con mucha potencia y
mucha frescura mucha originalidad como
Gabriel mamani y por supuesto hay
autores de otras épocas que
merecen ser más conocidos y que por
diversas razones no
no se conocen como podrían en
Más allá de las fronteras de Bolivia Uno
de ellos es el poeta Jaime Sáenz cuya
obra es realmente
extraordinaria no pero sí hay muchos
autores
bolivianos en este momento que están
empezando a hacer conocidos más allá
de Bolivia y también hay todavía muchos
autores de otras décadas
que que merecen ser leídos más allá de
Bolivia Muchas gracias Liliana y gracias
a ustedes por su confianza sigan con
nosotros hay más cultura en France 24 y
24 punto com
[Música]